[Musique]
préparer une élection c'est compliqué
c'est pour ça que depuis la fin de la
dernière élection générale en 2015
élections canada est au travail en
prévision du scrutin de demain
si entre deux élections 500 personnes
travaillent normalement pour l'organisme
élections canada emploie environ 300
mille travailleurs temporaires
le jour du vote le canada est un grand
très grand pays dans l'ensemble des 338
sa conception ce sont plus de 16 mai
locaux qui ont été louées dans des
écoles des centres communautaires des
centres commerciaux pour servir de
bureaux de vote en 2015 25 % des
électeurs avaient préféré voter par
anticipation une tendance à la hausse si
bien que cette année élections canada
ouvert plus de bureaux de vote par
anticipation et prolonger leurs heures
d'ouverture
cette année ce sont 27 millions
d'électeurs canadiens qui sont appelés
aux urnes
combien coûte une opération aussi
gigantesques en 2015 la facture de
l'élection en généralité de 443 millions
de dollars 53 % de plus qu'en 2011